welcome to Table Talk my name is Brett
I'm the pastor at the table where our
mission is to shift a generation from
reactionary to visionary through the
person in work of Jesus so they I want
to talk to you about two things that we
must stop first we must stop thinking of
ourselves as the next generation I
remember when I was the next generation
I knew I was the next generation because
I was told you are the next generation
let me tell you it's nice to be the next
generation no one expects much from you
and like the baby of the family everyone
can adults over you and lives the values
of the community towards you they are
kind to you they are patient to you they
bear with you yeah it's nice to be the
next generation but it's easy to forever
stay the next generation the person full
of potential and possibility but fear
holds you back
laziness tempts you to stagnation a lack
of faith hinders your growth stop it
step out be the generation be bold be
fearless live the values of your
spiritual tradition don't expect people
to make community for you create it for
others don't expect them to mentor you
mentor others and then what happens
mystery of all mysteries and stepping
out and laying down your life you
actually find it in creating community
for others you create it for yourself
in mintern and de cycling others you
learn and grow see joy comes to those
who stop obsessing about finding it for
themselves
and instead seek to bring it to others
being the next generation it's okay but
it's nothing compared to being the
generation okay but there's a second
thing we must stop number two we must
stop thinking of ourselves as the past
generation there's no such thing as
retirement in the kingdom of God of
course you may stop the 70 hour work
weeks you might reduce the endless
meetings you can refrain from being the
point leader of everything you're a part
of however you never check out you never
kick your feet up and say well my times
over had a good run I'll leave it to the
young folks to take it from here no the
young folks need you need your knowledge
your stories your wisdom your guidance
they need your skill sets that they need
your calm in the midst of the crisis you
are never the past generation until the
day they put you Six Feet Under
you are forever the generation and
mystery of all mysteries what happens
when you refrain from being the past
generation and instead embrace being the
generation vitality fills you purpose
echoes throughout your life meaning and
spiritual energy marked your everyday
being the past generation it's okay I
mean it's easy but it's nothing compared
to being the generation well that's all
for today if you enjoyed this video
please like and share it with all your
friends and subscribe Grace and peace